when someone outsources their truth that
is a
very scared person a brave person
doesn't outsource their truth
they they'll of course listen to the
council of outside sources
and they'll also cut off the council of
outside sources
when those outside sources don't
warrant their energy so i think a brave
person
listens to their heart their own mind
their own thinking
pays attention to their gut first and
foremost and of course will listen to
outside sources
and cut them off when they deserve to be
cut off
welcome to episode 90 of the michaela
peterson podcast
where i am joined by the one and only jp
sears jp series is a comedian who tours
the country extensively doing stand-up
comedy and publishing online videos
his videos have been viewed more than
500 million times
in addition to inspiring laughter in a
very weird world
jp's work takes an unapologetic stand
for freedom
free speech and encouraging people to
free themselves from
fear we discuss comedy political humor
counterculture escaping fear critical
thinking
living your own truth and much more and
some conspiracies
he basically told me my empathy was
narcissistic not sure if i agree sounds
like it's coming from someone who
doesn't score high on compassion
a facet of agreeableness but i could be
wrong let me know what you guys think
below i think jp's comedy is very
necessary
given the political atmosphere nowadays
he's spicy
this episode is brought to you by my
kratom sponsor superspeciosa
how could you sponsor kratom if you're
against pharmaceuticals
i'm not against pharmaceuticals exactly
i'm against treating a drug like it's
not a drug because a doctor gives it to
you
kratom is a natural herb related to the
coffee plant the leaves or extracts
from the leaves have been used as a
stimulant and a sedative kratom works on
opiate receptors in the brain so it's
been used to treat chronic pain
digestive ailments and aid in withdrawal
from opiate dependence
i trust the quality of kratom coming
from super speciosa
after i bought kratom in a sketchy
corner store in florida and it made me
very ill don't do that i think super
specious kratom can be
very beneficial if used properly some
people use superspeciosa for stress
management and to help them relax
i know how hard this past year has been
or this past
lifetime has been on people and
something like kratom tea is much safer
in my opinion
than a pharmaceutical superspeciosa has
different strains
some help you relax some give you energy
they might have you covered if you
check them out on their website it's
reliable third-party lab tested and
approved under the american kratom
association's quality standards program
if you do want to try kratom you can get
20 off by going to get
super leaf dot com slash mp
and enter the code mp for 20 off that's
get
super leaf.com slash mp promo code mp
for 20
off thank you super speciosa if you guys
enjoy this content please remember to
hit subscribe i hope you like it
[Music]
jp sears welcome to my podcast michaela
thank you for having me on your podcast
this is so cool i can remember watching
your first video when
i must have been 2012 or 2013 in
university
being like this guy is hilarious yeah
i can't remember what what the video
would have been well thank you so you've
you've been with me since the early days
probably since
uh back when i thought my videos were
crap
oh i didn't think they were crap yeah
but definitely early days i think 2013
and i think it was something that
was it was spread around facebook i
think i saw it on facebook not on
youtube or anything but i think it had
something to do with food
anyway it was funny i think you're funny
thank you i love the way you think
michaela please say more good things
about me
before we get started uh if anyone
watching doesn't know who you are
you start off by giving a brief
background about who you are and what
you do
yes so i identify
as a comedian and i make a lot of videos
online
and i do a lot of stand-up comedy
touring
and before it was due i've been doing
comedy for about seven years
or so maybe eight years and before i was
doing comedy i was doing life coaching
for 13 years super fulfilling work
helping
people help themselves and empower
themselves to
heal and grow past their self-imposed
limitations so
that was super cool and while i was
doing that i
was telling myself like it would be a
terrible idea
to let my natural sense of humor out
it'll like discredit me as a
life coach like whatever it is i thought
i was supposed to be like
i won't be that if i'm being myself and
then after
a number of years of you know not
letting me be
fully me in the professional light i
just kept having these ideas come to me
for you know conveying concepts through
the language of comedy they were coming
to me through like video ideas
i didn't know how to make videos and i
thought it was a bad idea bad for
business
but kind of like a i'd imagine a woman
having contractions going into labor
like the baby's gonna come
whether whether you like it or not
whether you think it's a bad
idea a good idea so the baby of
comedy uh came out and i thought i would
just
be like all right i'll make this one
stupid video nobody alike and
you know like whatever then i'll go eat
worms
but it more importantly it woke
something up inside of
me it was a level of creative
satisfaction and
fulfillment that i hadn't experienced
before and and
also just to sound a little artsy fartsy
i would dare say
i had a sense of spiritual connection to
a
heightened degree and i'd imagine other
some other creators could relate to what
i'm about to say but it didn't feel like
my creations
were like coming from my brain it kind
of felt like i was like
listening to the creative muse and
wherever the creative muse is whether
it's like cosmic
stuff or the creative muse is in
michigan i don't know
but just being connected to that to
listen and then express
is not only fulfilling but i'd say
highly
connective to me so i
became hooked and of course my my life
transformed professionally
and all the ways as i kept saying yes
to the comedy that wanted to live
through me so
yeah that's the lung and the short of my
background
wow okay how long after you started
putting out videos
did you kind of i want to say skyrocket
but did people start watching
so you know this is something i wouldn't
recommend
anybody count on but the my first one
went viral
and definitely not the second one it was
like probably a bunch more before
anything else caught traction but the
first one going viral
back at the time i uploaded it to
youtube it was called how to be
ultra spiritual and back then that is
what i
that's what i watched okay super cool
that's what i watched
that was great in in so back then
putting videos on facebook wasn't really
a thing it was just starting but it
wasn't like back then facebook was
there weren't videos on facebook but
someone
basically just stole it off my youtube
channel uploaded it to
facebook several pages did that and they
were getting millions of views on
their pages and and people would find me
from that
so i'm glad they stole it but yeah
the first one caught a lot of traction
and
in in a very codependent way but i think
functional
codependence that helped me realize that
god
there might be something here like
seeing
millions of people somehow appreciate
something i created
was very validating to me
do you think yeah yeah for sure do you
think your years of
helping people did you help people with
their health like how did you
how are you coaching people yeah so i
was doing
a combination of health coaching
nutrition and exercise
heavy on nutrition and exercise in my
early 20s
the way i would coach people but then it
it
progressed primarily into doing
emotional
work with people certainly under a
coaching umbrella
um so helping people a lot of times it
would
like what's going on in your life some
level of self-sabotage
dissatisfaction reoccurring
dysfunctional patterns in relationships
and oftentimes where we where we'd land
the work we'd be doing would be on
unresolved childhood issues
and in any way the the
i think to part of your question that
work with the
the people i was working with and
certainly i had to do that kind of work
on myself otherwise i'm just a
hypocrite uh that certainly laid the
groundwork for
how i do comedy the the comedy i do
it's usually it's got an intention of
somehow
helping people whether that's wake them
up out of the fear stupor they're living
in
uh wake them up to embracing
their power listening to their heart
you know being brave whatever it might
be
and and so i think the the work i was
doing previously
really helped pave the way to see
dysfunctional patterns in people
whether it's being limited by fear but
of course nobody walks around saying
like hey i'm limited by fear
like it nobody says that usually when
someone's limited
by fear they don't know they're limited
by fear so you have to of course
look for the clues so being able to look
for the clues
and then show those clues
in an exaggerated way through sarcasm
satire somehow through comedy
is something that you know i still do to
this day
so yeah my my comedy training i think
started long before i was
doing any level of comedy professionally
what kind of clues do you look for in
people if they're being motivated by
fear
yeah you know i think there's a bunch
the certainly one of the primary clues
is someone who's not fulfilled you know
the
they're not happy and i'm not talking
about gratified i think there's a huge
difference between gratification and
happiness
and i think a lot of times people call
gratification happy
they'll pick up their phone get a
dopamine hit by checking
instagram so they feel gratified
but they believe they're happy it's like
no no i'm happy
but they're not so i think a lack of
happiness and fulfillment is certainly a
part of it
people you know having a vision or a
dream of where they want to be
and them just
uh not going anywhere near that
repeatedly
i think are clues and then you know the
world we live in a
a very obvious clue is
when people are restricted by fear is
when people are being obedient to
authorities outside of themselves first
and foremost
so when someone outsources their truth
that is a very scared person a brave
person doesn't outsource their truth
they they'll of course listen to the
council of outside sources
and they'll also cut off the council of
outside sources
when those outside sources don't
warrant their energy so i think a brave
person listens to their heart
their own mind their own thinking pays
attention to their gut first and
foremost
and of course will listen to outside
sources and
cut them off when they deserve to be cut
off
so i think the world we live in like
that's one of the primary clues of
someone whose
religion has become worshiping fear
okay i i would agree how how would you
suggest
somebody start listening to their
instinct rather than
you know um i when i was sick uh and i
was paying attention to the medical
system i used to use logic
for all of my decisions yeah so like
this is what makes the most sense and i
completely
ignored my gut instinct because i
thought well that's not logical it
doesn't make any sense and if i can't
figure it out then it's wrong
which was overestimated overestimating
my cognitive abilities for sure
but how would you suggest people start
listening to what you call their own
truth yeah
you know i i'll i'll scoot back and
provide a little bit of context and then
hopefully if my brain's working i'll
actually
give a delusional opinion to that
awesome question of how do people
how can people start listening to their
own truth
um but taking a step back first in order
to do that i think someone's
relationship
with the feeling of fear
fear is a concept but the feeling of
fear has to change
so most of the time most people's
relationship
to the feeling of fear is one of
avoiding the feeling and of course the
feelings inside of them and they're
trying to avoid the feeling inside of
them so
there's a lot of escaping of themselves
many people just aren't willing to feel
the uncomfortability
of what it is to be afraid so it's much
easier to
be obedient the more obedient someone is
to whatever the outside authority is
the more they don't have to feel the
fear which the more they're trying to
not feel the fear
the more the fear is controlling them
that's why they become very obedient
but when the relationship changes
and you know fear is never going away
but does our relationship with
fear change when when someone's
what i'm just called in a brave state
they're not trying to avoid fear fear is
a
super freaking healthy human emotion
the unhealthy part is trying to escape
it but when someone is brave
they they're not looking to avoid fear
like okay like i'll do what you said
because like it doesn't make sense to me
but like
like it'd be really scary to do
something else and like face
social ridicule that's someone who won't
feel fear but a brave person's like oh
there's the fear
and you know what if i'm doing the thing
that i'm afraid of
that fear will intensify
and you know what i'm willing to feel
those feelings
so i think that relationship with fear
has to change
we have to become willing to not avoid
discomfort
but face discomfort renee brown
an author many people have heard about
she has a beautiful quote which i love
and it's
he or she who's willing to be the most
uncomfortable
is not only the bravest but rises the
highest
you know it's not virtualizing people
who are willing to avoid discomfort
it's it's praising and acknowledging
the heights we go when we're willing to
get uncomfortable
so i i share my
delusional redheaded perspective on how
our relationship with fear has to change
why because when we start listening to
our truth
it doesn't anesthetize fear my
experiences
the more we listen to our truth the more
the fears are provoked
the fears of like all the kind of like
the childish
ego parts inside of us like we're
listening to ourselves but we have the
well i shouldn't do this i could do this
i should have woulda coulda
and you know okay i'm listening to my
truth well that means
i'm cut off from the currency of
approval from other people
that's scary that [ __ ] doesn't go away
but the question is what are you gonna
do about it
feel the fears that come up and take
action anyway this action being
listen to your truth and abide your
truth or
are you gonna avoid it so i think the
the true
warrior of life that's the archetype i
think we all need
more of in the day we live in the true
warrior archetype is one who
is willing to feel fear
and take action anyway and the action is
inspired by
their own thinking their own gut their
own heart
their own self so
long story short my delusional point of
view is how we start listening to our
own truth
is by getting uncomfortable and
embracing it
being willing to feel afraid and
just a little asterisk footnote on that
i think it for me it's super helpful to
rewrite the perspective on
uncomfortability
because a lot of the programming i know
i used to carry and i think this
university of society teaches us
that if something's uncomfortable it's
bad for you
uh i kind of think the opposite is true
if something's uncomfortable it's
probably good for you
you take that with a grain of salt don't
get into a cage with a tiger that's
probably uncomfortable and probably very
bad for you but
having a sprinkling of common sense i
think
most of our growth and our happiness and
our fulfillment
doesn't come from our comfort zone i
think it comes when we're willing to be
brave enough to get out of our comfort
zone
i know i look at all the blessings i
have in my life
they all were born from the
the fertile grounds of vast discomfort
asking my wife out for the first time
i'm like hey there's a beautiful
powerful woman like oh i can't
get away out of my league so
uncomfortable
to tell her how i felt about her
stand-up comedy like
jesus christ getting on stage for the
first time like
talk about just like terror like that
nothing comfortable about that and it
doesn't get comfortable
quick i was willing to get uncomfortable
there you know having my
son like okay we're trying to get
pregnant life is gonna
change life was great and now we're
gonna change it like
so uncomfortable but those
the biggest blessings at least for me
are born out of discomfort
and our truth takes us in the direction
of the blessings not what
you know fauci tells us how it
fulfills bill gates agenda like uh
yeah not for me i'd rather listen to my
own truth
okay that was quite a response uh that's
a couple of things you said there were
interesting i've
so i've done some things that are
against mainstream you know medicine
and it's definitely been uncomfortable
but i always felt rather than operating
on bravery i always felt like
i i don't know if it's a guilt complex i
feel like it wasn't as healthy as just
being comfortable with being
uncomfortable i always felt like the
whatever i was avoiding was more
uncomfortable so when i started talking
about like my
what happened to me when i went on the
carnivore diet which was
super awkward to talk about because it's
an all meat diet and that's awkward
but not talking about it was making me
feel so awful
that talking about it was actually more
comfortable yeah so
as a as a former life coach is that an
unhealthy way to go about things
no i i think it's super healthy you know
you're yeah i think one of the paradoxes
of life's probably some universal rule
that
someone wrote on a cave wall somewhere
at some point in time
is you know we
our motivation to face pain oftentimes
comes from
creating enough pain from avoiding the
pain
and there's a that beautiful spiritual
quote by
i think a man or a woman i don't know
what it is but
uh their name is pronounced by me
anaya's
men and the quote is something along the
lines of
the when the risk to remain
tight in the bud became greater than the
risk of blossoming
yeah the flower blossomed i butchered it
but
it's kind of like yeah we have to
experience the pain
of avoiding something
build that up enough which then
motivates us to
all right now the pain avoiding this or
not doing this
is greater than the pain the risk of
just doing the damn thing and and i
think that's a
that's a a phase of learning and i don't
think that phase ever goes away but
it's a phase of learning and growth and
i think the more we do that
the the less time we have to spend
building up the pain to motivate us to
go
in the direction of our truth so maybe
when we're 10
we have to build the pain up to a level
100. like all right now i'll
like be myself at school instead of like
acting the way everybody wants
then maybe by the time we're 20 maybe
we're only building it up to 90. then 30
were okay we're making progress now we
only have to build it up to 75 then
we're 40.
then maybe we only have to build up the
pain of avoidance to like
50. so i think it goes down given
circumstances and are
that i think the more we learn like oh
relief
comes by ripping the band-aid off that's
painful
but relief comes the quicker and the
more fiercely
i face the thing that i'm afraid of
i think yeah okay oh no i i completely
agree
i've been uh i mean my dad is my dad and
he's taught me
from when i was little you know tell the
truth because not telling the truth
is more awful yeah like it's just more
awful it doesn't matter how bad the
truth is
not saying it doesn't make it go away
and it's more awful
and i still repeatedly learn that by
like telling myself stories about how
things are different than they are
and then realizing eventually uh you
know did a whole bunch of self-deception
there for a while [ __ ] not again
and then having to dig through that and
be like oh this is the truth yeah and
then it's
always a relief but yeah
it's wild i i i so relate to that
you know for me telling the truth
in in the simple terms of saying no
when it's a request and invitation of
something i either
genuinely don't want to do or it's
awesome but i just know
it doesn't fit into my priorities and
where my heart wants to devote my time
so man i for so many years i created so
much chaos in my life
by not being honest with a no i mean
sometimes it was like oh
let me sit with that that's awesome let
me get back to you and then i'm not
getting back to the person then they
become
in their relationship or i say yes and
then i'm showing up i'm resenting myself
like
i'm here instead of doing what i want to
do but man that honesty of
for me just when it comes to saying no
if nothing else
that honesty of like okay there's the
butterflies in my stomach i'm saying no
and then it's like oh holy hell life is
just
way better being honest
such great wisdom be honest
yeah that's hard i think it might be
harder
for some females too the saying no thing
because there's this well you're
supposed to be
i don't know if it's guilt or something
or if it's just something i have but
i've had trouble saying no and i'm
pretty disagreeable for a woman
but making people feel like saying no
and then having them be disappointed
yeah and then if i can feel that
disappointment that they're experiencing
and then i feel guilty so there's just
this like
it's a whole bunch of things it's hard
but it's worth it
i agree yeah it is hard and and i think
i
i can be as arrogant as you where i i
like take on the responsibility for
someone else's emotions like oh
that way you're making yourself feel i'm
doing that to you
i think that's actually a power trip
even though like it
when i do that like it feels bad on me
yet it also feels powerful like oh i
said no and that person's
upset like wow that's how important i am
to them
it's kind of like like a drop of
narcissism
and i'm not saying i'm above it i'm like
i do that like
hopefully i do it less than i used to
but that
yeah that self-imposed you know
guilt we put on ourselves because well
then how do you nothing
okay okay i like that i like that and i
think you're right about that
but how do you how do you disassociate
yourself from that
like i know that when i so this is i'm
gonna give you my story and then you can
tell me what you think about this
but when i was a kid and i and i used to
walk by homeless people on the street
if they were not doing well i'd cry so i
felt like i was picking like picking up
something from them so if i make someone
well
i should rephrase that if i tell
somebody something and they end up
feeling bad
and i feel bad is there a way that you
suggest i can like
not because i figured i was mirroring
but i think that you could be right
about like the drop of narcissism in
there as well
yeah you know um can i play hardball
with you michaela
yeah oh yeah bring it i i think empaths
are a real thing
and i think a lot of times empaths
become an escapism
uh for people to do their actual work
where it's much easier to say like oh
i'm feeling what that person's feeling
instead of saying no i'm actually
narcissistic and there's a childish part
of me
that believes that person is nothing
without me
therefore i said no or i'm you know not
helping them therefore their life is in
shambles and like they need more of me
in their life don't they
so i i think people can avoid deep
diving into that
really like some of that swamp land of
the soul work
by just saying like yeah i'm empathic
like i feel other people
so yeah you [ __ ] feel yourself more
than anybody
so you know
and by the way like i'm i still have so
many fingerprints all over this
landscape
i still do this maybe less than i used
to
but i'm still there and and for me one
of the
easiest most powerful ways to
dissociate from kind of getting sucked
into this whirlpool
is to name it you know the wise man ram
das
once said you can't get out of the jail
you don't know you're in so
if you become aware of the jail that you
otherwise didn't know you're in
and then verbalize it name it
all right now we just empowered
ourselves to
right off the bat spend less time in
this
self-constructed jail cell of suffering
over other people's suffering
so when we can name it you know my
self-talk will be something and i don't
mean this shamefully but it's just how i
name it
they're like oh there's that arrogant
part of me that thinks
someone else's life is nothing without
me
or someone else you know their their
life revolves around me and
look at them suffer because of me so
it's like a playful way of naming it
just so i can be more aware of the jail
that my childish self puts me in
and and i say childish self because i
you know this is a pattern i certainly
learned when i was a kid i
took on the role of let me be
responsible for my whole family
says a four-year-old like pretty
arrogant yeah
and not functional but super arrogant
but it's how i coped like cool like
mom's got anxiety dad's doing this or
that they're
trouble in their marriage so let me be
responsible
for their emotional well-being and their
relationship
and let me be responsible for holding
this world together
so taking on the impossible task of
being
responsible for other people's emotions
is something i've done a lot of
now the interesting thing is i don't
think we ever can
be responsible for other people's
emotions it's a trick we play on
ourselves
like their mind and heart makes them
feel what they feel i didn't
i didn't make them upset their
experience of me
made them upset so
um to me like giving ourselves our
birthright back to be free
has a lot to do with handing the
responsibility
for other people back to them
we're not free unless we do that
we all do that so it's just a matter of
like
how much can we catch ourselves doing it
and how much can we
you know do our best to course correct
and name it when we're doing it so we do
it less often
cool okay well that's definitely
something i most definitely have to work
on
yeah and i've noticed that and i've been
aware of it and been like you know if
someone's suffering and you go over
there and like cry
one it's like it's not helpful yeah it
was like
so i'm like what is this this has got to
stop okay
that's interesting that's interesting
now just start yelling at him like tell
him to toughen up
yeah just go the opposite direction yeah
that'll work close off emotionally go in
that opposite
direction okay
um how so i guess you did you did quite
a switch in the last
couple of years and you're doing a lot
more of your comedy on
politics and just political things that
are going on which isn't that
surprising given the state of especially
north america but the um the state of
the us with covet and everything but
what
is it that made you change from more of
the like health and wellness comedy to
the
political commentator commentary i would
say yeah
i love that i had no intention of
getting into politics
i never found it interesting i always
found it a waste of time and it's just
like
these faces these figure heads that
aren't doing anything just make a lot of
noise never interested in that
then our freedom started getting taken
away that impacted me and
and specifically when kovid stopped
becoming a medical issue
and started becoming a political issue
which still blows my mind it also tells
me
ain't a medical issue if they're just
making a political issue
that's how i interpret it so when covid
became a political issue rather than a
medical issue
that's when i really started notice my
freedoms are getting taken away
my friends freedoms are getting taken
away in ways that
are sure as hell not justified
and then april 7th of last year my wife
and i found out we're pregnant and i i
know you've got a little one and
i'm sure you've got your similar
experience but
there's something flipped inside of me
just like this
you know three million year old primal
father
instinct of
i want to make this world as
good of a place as possible
not just for me but for my son
so as i saw freedoms being eroded away
and of course like if someone
someone's vision goes forward you can
see not just
here's the freedoms taken away today but
you can see
where that will go if it's not checked
and and so having my son on the way
became
very motivating to me and
and at the time the idea of like all
right like
apparently now code is a political issue
and anytime you go into politics you
divide the audience
piss off a bunch of people at that time
i was thinking like
i don't want to piss my audience off but
the pain of not saying what i need to
say would be far
greater than the pain of losing some
audience or whatever
so i just i stayed dedicated to
speaking my unapologetic perspective
and calling bs
and calling tyrancy where i saw it
it doesn't mean i'm always right
definitely
right some of the time certainly play
the odds
so i stayed dedicated to that and
and to me we have nothing without
freedom
so it's kind of like all right in the
faces
since i've been censored i've been
warned by all the platforms
and of course i do my best to know our
what are the red flags that
the big tech tyrants will just
automatically eject you out of
youtube or facebook i want to do my best
to reach the people
so i need to be where the people are but
yeah but i also can't be silenced so
the censorship i think it's made me a
better comedian because i've had to
become more artful in saying what i have
to say
without saying the thing absolutely
directly
that'll get me censored so when i looked
at that
it's like all right my son's coming into
the world censorship's
ramping up it's already been happening
to me i've people i know have been
de-platformed
but i just knew like all right we
we have nothing without freedom so i
would rather speak
my truth and do my best to help people
and help the world which means i'm
helping my son
into the future i'd rather do that
and risk losing the online empire i've
built up
i would rather speak my truth and have
to pick up cans on the side of the
highway to feed my
family in the name of doing my best
to make the world better for my sons so
um the freedom switch got flipped in me
last year and
which by the way i mentioned i was
afraid of losing honest
my audience just exponentially grew
there's nothing i've ever done that's
been better for audience growth
than be unapologetic with my truth
and and seeing how my audience has grown
so much i've realized
the the perspectives i'm speaking
you know if people aren't watching my
stuff and my audience isn't growing
by leaps and bounds because i'm some
good-looking guy
it's growing so much because what i am
saying
has become the voice for many voiceless
people
who either don't have a platform
and or their views aren't represented
by any of the media that they're exposed
to so
uh people need a voice and at times we
find surrogates to voice our voice
they're saying what we have to say so
uh it's been an honor to become that
for people and of course uh what's most
important
is for people to find their voice like
you got to voice what you need to voice
i'll be the surrogate hopefully an
inspiration for a little while but
you've got to be brave enough to voice
your voice as well but
anyway so that's been a a pretty
exciting
um occurrence to see along the way the
past year or so that i've
ventured into the arena of politics
because
that's where the the
treasure of freedom has been plopped
yes i like i like the way you put that i
was gonna ask you a question on how
you've avoided
being canceled uh can you tell me is it
possible to tell me what you're not
allowed to talk about
i feel like that's something like are
there topics that you
artfully avoid specifically yeah you
know certainly
um and i'll say them so explicitly
because i want to get you censored
michaela
just kidding um no certainly vaccines
that is just that is the most censored
topic i mean you get
doctors on youtube talking about
vaccines and they ban them
it's like holy hell a doctor what the
hell um
so you can't say anything about vaccines
that's not towing the propaganda
mainstream media
narrative about it youtube has also been
very explicit of
you can't say any misinformation about
coven
which means you can't speak any
information about covid
that's not toeing the propaganda lines
and you know certainly the election here
in the u.s uh
last fall into the new year
that was a very hot topic i had to be
very
careful around that and yeah so
those are certainly some of the topics
and
i'm trying to think what else i i know
climate change is coming down the
pipeline already it's
it's quite censorable if you're
questioning any of the narratives around
climate change and
and i know you know thanks to something
like the
undercover work of project veritas
exposing the
corruption at cnn you know the cnn has
literally said recorded in
um undercover tape that they will be
pumping climate change
in order to create more fear in people
and so yeah like anymore like i
i really i love questioning
fear-based narratives and anyway climate
change is another one coming down the
pipeline that
uh they will be excited to censor
uh okay changing topics slightly what is
what is your
that's good to know that's kind of what
i figured um
i started this section on my podcast
called opposing views
where i'll have one view on and
the opposite view on yeah and so i'm
seeing if that's okay
so far it seems to be okay like here's
the one
like alternative realistically
alternative view and here's the
mainstream view but i'm showing both of
them so
yeah that seems to be okay for now i
mean thank you for doing that like
god help us all if there's only one
point of view
like and god like i don't i don't even
want just my point of view
like i've never been right about
everything in my life so
i mean you just think of how crappy the
world would be
if you only had your point of view you
never had contrasting views
it's just like a muscle that never has a
weight to lift
that muscle is not going to get stronger
it's going to get weaker
smaller it's going to atrophy and i
think our minds and our perspectives are
like that times 10. yeah plus it
confuses people
because if they have an idea and no one
else is saying it they're like well
is it reasonable is it real like what's
real if no one else is talking about
something that you think might exist
that's just screws with people
okay okay switching directions like i
said what is your
favorite conspiracy theory oh
man well that
you gotta that's a fun question there's
so many michaela
i think my my favorite conspiracy
theory that i don't believe in
because like anymore i look at like what
the mainstream media and what social
like the tech giants call conspiracy
theories i'm like well
i don't believe in anything that's not a
conspiracy theory
based on their definitions of it um
but you know my man
i was gonna say that the one that i
think is
not true would be flat earth i think
that's just fun
cool the earth is flat and let's just
get irate about that but my favorite
conspiracy
theory that i certainly don't know for
sure if it's true or false but i really
question that
is the moon landing you know i
okay i look you know i've watched plenty
of
stuff like views of like here's why we
think it was faked and it's like
that adds up um so i could see how it's
possible
and now i'm seeing like the freaking
year the past year we've lived in yeah
you see how much the government
tries to manipulate people's
perspectives
through the propaganda networks the
mainstream media
and of course now how the the
democratic left in the u.s controls the
tech giants
looking at that same like yeah
like they they coulda
they they could have faked the whole
thing could they
fool a nation into thinking we landed in
the moon
well they fooled a nation into believing
they need to stay in their [ __ ]
houses for a year
so do i think they have the manipulative
power to do that
yeah do i think they have the
soullessness to do that yeah
and it's also possible we landed on the
moon so
yeah moon landing is one of my favorites
yeah i think when i well when i started
this carnivore diet
i was just like oh my god this is a
possibility what else do i know
what else do i think is right that isn't
and i just
you know it's like [ __ ] it could be
anything if i can only eat meat and be
okay
if i can only meet and then put myself
into remission
it's like it could be anything what a
powerful question
you know what else do i think is true
isn't i
i have to ask michaela what's your
favorite conspiracy theory
okay let me think what is my favorite
conspiracy theory
i'm worried i'm gonna say this and the
comments
the comments are just going to be
michaela that that's real though
that's real of course um okay okay so
one of the i really like the reptilian
one
i don't know a lot about that but i
really want to have people on the
podcast who are like full believers in
these conspiracy theories and just talk
to them to see what they're like
yeah uh because that sounds extremely
entertaining
but the reptilian one which i think was
when you saw
like a tv that kind of like glitched
yeah and you're like that's their true
form
shifting real quick yeah that's a good
one
um and then oh man i'm not gonna be able
to remember his name i've been seeing
him
advertised all over instagram
um no i don't have it i'm gonna stick
with reptilians
i love the reptilian ones good for you i
love that one
uh i think do you know who david ike is
that's actually who i was talking about
who's advertised all over
what do you think about him so i think
different things about him but first off
if you want to have a reptilian
race conversation he's your guy i want
him on
reach out to him um but you know i think
different
things about him you know first off i've
never
met a single human where i agree with
everything they have to say
never not even myself don't agree with
everything i have to say
i changed my mind all the time so i
i i've listened to some things that he's
had to say i'm like man that's
that's outrageous and then
you know the world turns it's like all
right what he said few years ago that i
thought was just
ludicrous i kind of believe
and then you know other things he has to
say are
not outrageous but just not certainly
not mainstream perspectives but just
straightforward man like
that feels like you're speaking truth
brother
so i i personally i really appreciate
him and his work
and again this i know he's like
people love to like discredit him by
saying he's a conspiracy
theorist well i think those who like to
discredit people with conspiracy label
conspiracy theorists like there's a
conspiracy that they're falling into
which is getting them out of touch with
their own mind by
labeling free thinkers is conspiracy
theorists so long story short
i like his stuff okay
i wanted to get him on i watched some of
his stuff and i was like
whoa that's wild we definitely need to
talk
did you see his so like last spring
into early summer he did a series of
long
form wonderful interviews with brian
rose of
london reel i saw that brian rose had
had him
on i didn't watch the full thing the the
first
two i think i only watched the first two
interviews they did but first off like
you know youtube just wants to censor
the crap out of that
uh which always raises my eyebrow like
why if what he's saying is not true
why are you getting so defensive big
tech so
to me that actually adds more
credibility to david
but the the first two interviews david
ike did with london rose
i thought were really intriguing and his
take home message
was so pure and tangible which is
don't function out of fear function out
of love you're not controllable
unless you're afraid
that was my take-home message yeah so
bad
yeah yeah i i always okay if i'm trying
to play devil's advocate i assume that
the reason
this is devil's advocate advocate but i
would assume the reason
people like david ike are censored is
because they think that
i don't know who they is but they think
that his ideas
are dangerous and that mass amounts of
people will start believing him and
it'll upset society
um that would be my devil's advocate
thoughts what do you think about that
yeah
yeah i think that sounds very reasonable
and
and if i was playing devil's advocate to
that
devilish advocate i would say i i i
bet that is the the big tech
censorship um
spoken rationalization for censoring him
yet i would also
be very suspicious that they have a
deeper reason for censoring him which
is maybe just the opposite
not so much hey what he's saying is so
false it might
influence people and negatively
influence society
but some of what he says is so true
it will upset the control that we're
trying to impose on society
so who knows that that's just what
you know the devil's advocate to the
devil's advocate
um might say yeah it's
but also you know my thought is like
i have so much respect for human
intelligence
if someone is speaking complete
[ __ ] let people
use their own intelligence to sniff it
out
like you know we don't censor dog [ __ ]
on wands
like it's not like mandated like dogs
aren't allowed to poop on the ground
because we know people are intelligent
most of the time
to have their eyes open and not step in
dog [ __ ]
so man i i don't think we need
authoritative bodies like big tech and
the government
treating people like they're mentally
handicapped three-year-olds
i think people are yes very intelligent
and i think people's superpower is
self-responsibility
i think be people become very
disempowered
when they're trained to be obedient to
rely
on external powers
i agree i agree
yeah it's insulting right having your
having your information
censored for your own safety it's like
come on guys
i'm descending it's like yeah it's very
condescending it's like having the
waiter at the restaurant
chew your food for you and spit it in
your mouth
you look so weak you probably can't chew
your food
you probably don't know how let me do
that for you
[ __ ] off yeah
yeah exactly okay okay
let's wrap this up with
you are in incredibly good shape as i
have seen
from your youtube videos um what is your
diet what is your diet and exercise kind
of schedule like what is what does that
look like and then
ending with do you have a morning
routine yes what does your lifestyle
look like
yeah i appreciate you asking it's uh
yeah pretty the 100 000 foot view from
above is
pretty darn clean eating so the the diet
is you know a lot of fat
a lot of animal based protein
not no carbohydrates but low-ish on the
carbohydrate
um i very very little processed food i
like only
like if i'm out like on a special treat
so
whole food high fat
high protein diet is what i'm doing
i also intermittent fast so
usually between the hours of like 7 pm
at night is
when i'll have my last meal and then
usually i don't eat until
12 p.m or 1 p.m the next day
i just love it it doesn't feel at all
like a stretch or i'm going without but
i love it
and apparently there's awesome benefits
to it that people that are smarter than
me
can i tell you about that i can't i'm
just like i feel great with it
and then my exercise
usually probably
four days a week i'm doing weights and
i've got my
home gym just here in the garage with
free weights kettlebells
pull ups functional stuff just
basic stuff but yeah usually in there
for an hour or so
four days a week and yeah that that
helps keep
me sane mentally
and it's for me one of my my
prime ways to de-stress psychologically
i i think we've got like the primal ape
inside of us
that it it needs it it needs to get
wild it needs to grunt it needs to
scream
it needs to exert you know journaling
talking processing all great
stuff but there's also a [ __ ] gorilla
inside of us that just needs to
roar so picking up heavy stuff and
grunting and getting primal even if it
didn't do anything
for my body i'd still do it
because it it benefits me um
yeah so that's the the gist of my diet
and exercise
and my morning routine yes
so i i make coffee and
then i usually stretch for
20 or 25 minutes kind of like yoga-ish
stretching and then i've got
like a few affirmations that i go
through out loud
and yeah that that's the gist of my
morning routine
and then i usually float right into my
work day
but i front load creative time on my
work day so that's
creative time is i guess blended into my
morning routine as well
when what time do you go to bed and wake
up when i'm
like treating myself well
i'll go to bed by 10 and wake up 6 or 6
30.
and then also though that's my ideal it
doesn't always happen i've been on a
pretty good stretch with that lately but
you know there was you know a couple
months straight where i was getting
three to five hours of sleep at night
you know i'm just up late
doing a lot of video work and then
travel doing comedy shows on the
weekends
unless we have a five month old so um
that is just kind of like you know it in
bed
one or two up at six and
but yeah ten to ten to six or six thirty
i'll feel really good doing that
and if you can hear my dog wally he's
saying that i'm lying about something
no i'm not how has okay this is my last
question then
how has uh you're in austin
and how has that been for i mean if you
have a five month old then it's gotta be
it's a little bit
isolating it was for me anyway at the
beginning having a baby so has it been
isolating or have you been able to like
keep in contact with people yeah
so it has having a five month old it has
been
isolating in
in many ways but there's also some level
of contact so the isolation comes where
in our tight-knit friend group there's
only one other couple that
has a child and he's like 10 months old
now
and but everybody else is
without children at this point and
awesome good for them but they're just
able to do stuff where it's like
man thanks for the invite but coming out
at 6 00 p.m
i mean wilder's got to go down at 7 00
p.m so
if we disrupt that then my wife's
getting far less sleep and then she'll
be
tired the next day which means she'll be
angry at me for no reason and like
uh we're gonna sit this one out so
there's certainly been a lot of that
and then but we have just the best
friends in the world where
they're just so cool with supporting us
like cool if you need to sit this out
awesome and then other times you know
we're making sure we're doing
get-togethers earlier in the day
so but i will say by nature i am
quite introverted so the isolation that
comes with kind of
really yeah the the the
how you kind of protect the nest with
quietness and when you know we sleep
early in the evening with a
five-year-old that's
then i i don't mind that at all as a
introvert
i cannot believe that you're introverted
how do you manage are you just super
disagreeable
like how do you manage to do the kind of
things you do and go on stage and be a
comedian if you're an introvert
yeah and what personality test have you
been using it's great questions so
uh man i've i don't know what the
personality test is
it's more of a like just knowing myself
kind of thing
so i think for me i can extrovert pretty
well
you know and i love extroverting
but it i'm not an extroverting endurance
athlete it's more of a sprinter like if
i
get together with someone for three
hours over dinner
i'm exhausted by the end of it this is a
great person great friend
but okay like i need so much quiet time
and you know on weekends doing a bunch
of comedy shows like cool on stage
obviously that's had the extroversion
but then i'm in my hotel room
like regrouping a lot so i do notice
my tank it drains pretty quick with
extra version
and while my tank still has juice in it
i love the extra version i
absolutely do so it's kind of like a
gender fluid with introversion and
extroversion like i love the extrovert
but i gotta like spend more time
introverting
okay you know what that might be and i
know
i know quite a bit about personality
from my dad you
it sounds like you are introverted if
being in the social situations kind of
like drain you at the end yeah you might
just be extremely open
and extremely open people are just like
they'll go and do things
even if they're not naturally
extroverted
when you say extremely open like
what does that mean um openness in
is a personality trait in the big five
so that's openness
openness conscientiousness extroversion
agreeableness and neuroticism so
openness is a
is a personality trait and people who
are
more open politically are more likely to
be liberal
but they're more interested in new ideas
and new experiences
um that's one way to talk it's open to
experience basically
so open to ideas and open to experience
people who are low in openness
don't really want to go travel they
don't want to see different things they
don't want to hear different views
so some people who are like kind of
emotionally stable and introverted if
they're
super high in openness they'll go out
and do things
and talk to people and be on stage even
if they're not actually extroverted yeah
that makes sense yeah
it could very well be me it could be you
okay thank you very much for coming on
uh if people want to find you and
don't know where to look where should
they go yeah
the single best place my website
awakenwithjp.com
from there there's links to all my
social medias
um so yeah wiccan with jp.com is a great
way to
connect with me any way you'd like
cool okay thank you very much for saying
yes to the podcast invite
oh yeah thank you for having me on
michaela and thank you for
having the voice that you do and in
sprinkling wisdom and perspective on
society we need it and i love your
perspectives
and and you have a great voice so thank
you for doing what you're doing
wow thank you very much
[Music]
you